this guy has got to be the most cursed
player to ever touch CS go if you guys
want to see a trick the legendary pimp
tricks returning in Counter-Strike 2 the
first ever played trick you want to top
down middle like this
pimp is a former CS Go Pro and a
legendary animal but he's probably best
known for his hemp tricks you guys want
to see trick it's just too right you got
to see a trick all right you smoke out
like this let me jump up it's a little
skill jump right here
forget you
whenever pimp tries to show his chat
something cheeky or useful the gods of
Cs go Smite him for it oh God made like
this you actually need two flashes for
it I'm just gonna do one though
should work okay very time
why does that stuff happen